All right, so there's there's a bunch of ways you
can imagine doing this. And here's, here's how I would
suggest looking at it. So, for each of these 28
positions, there's some number of steps that it's going to take
before it either resets, that is to say, you know,
re, re, re-chooses at random, or has actually reached the
tippy top. So, let's, let's actually evaluate these. So if
you, if you happen to start at 1, how many steps
is it before you realize that you, that you're
at 1? You have to evaluate 1, you have to
evaluate 2, you have to evaluate 3, and you have
to evaluate 4 to see that you're at local optimum.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, there's going to be 4 evaluations if you start at 1. If you
start at 2, then it's going to be 1, you're going to have to evaluate 1,
2, 3, and 4 again. If you start 3, then you only need to
evaluate 2, 3 and 4 to know that you are at a local optimum.
>> Hm-mm.
>> If you start 4, then you have to evaluate 4
and then if you randomly step in this direction, you are also
going to need to evaluate 2, 2 and 3. All right. So
then, I, I finished writing down what all these different numbers are.
For each, at each position here, I wrote down in red,
how many steps it's going to take before it hits a local optimum
including the ones here around the actual peak. And I wrote
two numbers for the places that were these cusps where it can
go either way. So, now, we can actually work
out what the expected number of steps to the
global optimum is. It turns out for 22 out
of 28 of these points, the average 5.39 before they
discovered that they're at a local optimum, at which
point we have to start the whole process over again.
And so whatever the expected value of reaching the
local optimum is, we have to, we incur that same
cost again.
>> That makes sense.
>> Good. Okay. So, for 4 out of 28.
These guys here. Then, they're going to take 4 steps on
average and end up with the peak. Then, the only
other things that left to figure out or what happens
at these two weird cusps where just a flip. It's
going to flip a coin and either get stuck on a
local optimum that's not global or go to the global
optimum. So, in 2 out of 56 of these cases
it's going to have chosen to go to the local
optimum. The non global local optimum. And it just so turns
out that it's 10 in both of those cases. It's
10 steps before you realize you're stuck again. At which point
it's going to start the whole process all over again
because it's stuck. Then in 1/56th of the cases, we're going to
be here and choose to go to the right and, and
take six steps to get to the global and here 1/56th
of the cases we're going to take five steps to get to the global.
>> Okay, so just to be clear, so the way you got 28
is that there are 28 numbers and you uniformly chose where to start.
>> Yep.
>> Where you got 56 is, you decided that for two of
those numbers 15 and 20 you end up getting them 1/28th of
the time. And then half of the time you do. The local
optimum and half the time you end up doing the global optimum.
And it just turns out that in the case, in
the cases where you end up going through the local
optimum, those both happen to take 10 steps. And that's
how you got 2 out of 56. And the last
thing to notice is that for point number 4, where
you could go to the left or to the right,
since you do each half the time, it's like saying
the number of steps there is just uh,11 over 2.
>> On
average. Yeah. Very good. So that was folded into
this 5.39 number. You're right. Thanks for pointing that out.
>> Okay. Sure. So this all makes sense and obviously if you just add
those all up you can solve for V and the answer is [COUGH] exactly.
>> So, just algebraically simplifying this equation gives us V
equals 5.36 plus 0.82 V. Solving for V gets us 29.78.
So, it only takes 29.78 function valuations
before we first hit the maximum. Ta-da.
>> Michael?
>> Yes sir.
>> So, that seems unfortunate. Because here's a really simple algorithm, for
i equals or, hey let's say x. For x equals 1 to 28.
Compute f of x. If it's bigger than my previous one,
then hold on to it. And then just return whatever is the biggest number
I see. So, that's linear and that's 28 evaluations, which is less than 29.78.
>> Yeah, that's a good algorithm in this case. But you, I,
I guess your point is that this, this whole idea of hill climbing
and using this, this local information is actually costing us a little bit
compared to just enumerating all the possible inputs and just testing them off.
>> Right. Which
I guess makes sense because the numbers
are really small and [UNKNOWN] and you have
a whole bunch of local optima, and so it's going to take you a long time to
luck into the right one. But, it seems kind of sad that there's nothing clever
you can do here to do better than 28, which is kind of what you want to do.
>> Well, there's a couple clever things we
could do, right? So one is, we could random
restart faster. It turns out [INAUDIBLE] magic [INAUDIBLE].
So here's a question. What happens if you randomly
restart after each function evaluation? How many function evaluations do
we have to do, on average before we reach the maximum?
>> I don't know. Oh, well, I guess it would be less than 28.
>> It would be exactly 28.
>> Oh it would?
>> Yeah.
>> 28's less than 28 so that's, that's fair.
>> It's less than or equal to it, sure.
>> Yeah, yeah, that's what I meant.
>> And even better what happens if we actually
keep track of points that we visited in the past?
>> Then we don't pay
the cost for re-evaluating them.
>> That's right.
>> So, then the only question is how long does it
take us to luck up into getting between 15 and 20.
>> Yes. Well, once we. Yeah, once we fall
into that zone, then we're going to be done shortly afterwards.
>> Right. so, how much of a, how much of a win is that on average?
>> That's a good question. It's a little bit hard to tell. Because
what's going to happen is if we follow this algorithm with the additional thing,
additional attribute that says. If you already know
the function valuation from som, from some previous iteration.
We just reuse it, we don't get, we don't
pay the cost for that. Then what's going to happen
is we're going to get dropped off in random
places in this space. We're going to hill climb visiting
some things along the way. And possibly get drops
in place where we've already done the function evaluation.
>> Right.
>> And therefore don't
have to pay that cost again. But it's not as
simple as saying how many different hops do we take
before we land in this basin because if we land
in say this basin here, the second one from the
left. If, if we you know get dropped onto point
14, it's going to stay in that zone for a while,
which is actually kind of bad because it's taking lots
of function evaluations in that same part of the space.
>> But look. But what you just said is important,
right? Since we're only, we're only going to pay the cost
of doing the function evaluation once, that means in the worst
case. We would end up hitting the three bad basins before
we hit the fourth basin. In fact, we would end up
hitting the three bad basins enough times that we would end up
visiting all of the points in them. So we'd land in
0.14 which would get us all the way over to the
peak and just to the left, and then we would land
in 5.5, which would get us to the right, so we cover
everything in the basin. So, the worst case
is we cover every single point in all
three of the basins before we get lucky enough to land in the, the good basin.
>> Right.
>> And then. But, the moment we land in the good basin, we will get
to. Am I right? We will get to avoid at least one of those numbers.
>> No. Not necessarily. So, for example, if we
start at 15 and we randomly move to the right.
To know that we're at the optimum here, we have
to check the point 19. So we've actually touched everything.
>> No, we didn't touch 20.
>> Well, we may have already, unluckily, hit 20
because it's part of the right hand basin as well.
>> That's true.
>> But anyway, the point is that you're right.
If we keep track of which points we've already visited,
then we can't do worse than 28. Like, even if
we're really, really unlucky, we can't do worse than 28.
>> Right.
>> Maybe, maybe on average it will be a little
bit better than that. But but only one or two.
>> But it will still be better.
>> I think it still be better.
>> On average, on average it will be better.
>> Yeah, its true. I think, I think in this case
it's, it's just a contrived example with lots of local optima and
just a linear space so that there's a the, the attraction base
ends up being relatively small compared to the size of the space.
>> Hm. Okay, that makes sense. So, what,
what should I learn from this? So I guess
what I learned is randomized optimization or randomized hill climbing, here, may
not do better than evaluating all this space in the worst case, but it won't do
any worse. And every once in a while, you will get lucky and do
much better. At least if your cost is function evaluations, as opposed to steps.
>> That's right. Yeah and also, well and I, and, the
thing that I was hoping, that you'd notice is this idea
that randomized hill climbing, depends a lot on the size
of the attraction base and around the global optima. So if
we make that really big, then this is a huge win.
If we make it really small then it's less of win.
>> No and that makes a lot is right. So if,
if, if the third one, had gone all the way from
say number 3 to number 26. Then you would fall into
it immediately and you would just, you would get there very quickly.
>> Right.
>> Okay, yeah, I see that, that makes, that
makes a lot of sense. So, so when you asked
me before what the advantages are, the advantages
are, you know, you, you're in a place
where the attraction basin for your global optima
are in fact, relatively big. If you could,
once you luck into that part of the space and there's lots of ways to luck
into that part of the space, you can get there very quickly. So it's a big win.
>> Agreed.
>> Okay, good. You know, okay, that makes sense to me, I like that.